ﾔﾊﾞ、ﾔﾊﾞ・・・マジヤバい、マジヤバい・・・
あれ俺財布どうしたっけ？
財布？俺さっきどっかでみたぞめんちゃん
あったじゃん！
ベイブレード持ってかなきゃ！
ベイブレード持ってくの？
うん
はい、はい、ハイおはようございます・・・・・・・本日はこんにちはユーチューブ、こんにちは　ハロハローユーチューブ
ハイと言う訳で今は、今から東京に行きます、今から東京、、、ﾁｮｯﾄ・・・
はい、と言う訳でですね、今から東京に行くんですけども、この前話したと思うんですけども
東京の新居に何を置けばいいかという話をしました。
ホントに時間が無いからね
いろんな意見が有ったんですけども、僕がいろんな意見の中で、良いと持ったやつが一つありまして、
それがこちらです
ダークネス井上です。
ダークネス井上、所沢と撮影部屋にいると場所が被って狭すぎて置く場所がない！
彼には居場所が無い。そんな可哀そうな彼をどうするか？
今まではずっと寝室に置いていた！  でもこれからは東京と言う新たな舞台でこいつは僕と一緒に動画を撮る事が出来ます。
というわけで今回今から新幹線で、東京に行くんですけども・・・行こう！時間ヤバい、マジヤバい
と言う訳で今から東京に・・・、いや待って、エアコン・・・
ハイと言うわけで今から東京に行くんですけども、新幹線でね？、、、今から新幹線で東京に行くんですけども
僕にはもう移動手段が今、新幹線しかないので、果たしてダークネス井上を連れて、僕は新幹線で・・・
東京までダークネス井上を連れて行けるのかという、ちょっと検証をしてみようと思います。
時間との戦いだよねマジで
何かポイントになるところはホントに新幹線に乗れるかって言う
大きいんですよね・・・。
人間１人分の席は取れそうですよね？
でも払えば確実じゃない？でもこいつ分の席を払えば多分、間違えなく乗せてもらえそうだよね
ぶつかったらさぁ、車がさあ、ほら・・・
ああ、エアバッグ
エアバッグ
ああ、それかぁ
なんかデフォルトエアバッグ状態みたいな
ダークネスが果たして新幹線に乗れるか、どうかってのが先ずポイントになります。
そもそも乗れなかったらもう、こいつは新幹線に乗せる事がダメなので、１席分払へれば乗せてもらえそう
「起きて、めんちゃん」
はい、はいありがとございます
「こんな人初めて見たよ、めんちゃん」
いや、これもすべてこいつの為だよ
「新しいお家？」
ああ、いつもコイツ、淋しそうだったんだよ。
いつも寝室で所沢を羨ましそうに見てて、俺にも何かできないかな、っていつも思ってたんだ。
人の邪魔にならない様に、端っこから行きましょう
はい、ひとまずダークネスが新幹線に乗れるかどうか先ず訊かなきゃいけないのでとりあえず聞きます。
…座席をもう一個・・・あ、できない？・・・あ、分かりました、ありがとうございます。
ダメらしいｗww
どーしよ、え？ 待ってそうなるとどうやってダークネスをさぁ…東京まで運べばいいの？
完全に詰んだこれはw
と言う訳で、大きなぬいぐるみは新幹線に持ち込まないようにしましょう。